اذا عصر جديد من الحرب افتتحته كييف
فالمسرح بات مهيئا لجيلا جديد للقدرات
العسكريه محوره الذكاء الاصطناعي ودرون
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه شرعت الابواب
لتطوير هذا السلاح وزادها تقدما وحنكا ان
صح التعبير الذكاء الاصطناعي الذي فتح
المجال للسوق كبير وفعال في ذات الوقت
بالمجال العسكري وفق محللين عسكريين هذه
المخيرات لا تقدر بثمن لا سيما في خطوط
المواجهه الاماميه فهي صغيره رخيصه يمكن
ان تقدم بثا مباشرا لمواقع العدو وبشكل
دقيق الطائرات المسيره وان كانت بطيئه
وعرضه لنيران الاسلحه الصغيره يمكن
استخدامها ضمن اسراب لارباك الدفاعات
الجويه وبعضها قد يخترقها ايضا وهنا
بالمقارنه مع الصواريخ فالاخيره تطير
بسرعه عاليه ويصعب اسقاطها لكنها تكلف
مئات الالاف او ملايين الدولارات وفي وقت
استخدمت روسيا المسيرات لقصف الم دن
الاوكرانيه وايضا البنيه التحتيه الحيويه
اعتمدتها اوكرانيا بكثافه لضرب المراكز
اللوجستيه الروسيه ووفرت لها ميزه التقدم
بالحرب علما بان سوق الدرون ضل محصورا
بتسليم الطرود المحليه وربما عروض الاضاءه
حتى اندلاع الحرب الاوكرانيه التي اظهرت
امكاناتي الهائله
[موسيقى]
المسيرات التي كثفت خروجها واستهدافاتها
وافشلت سيطره الروس على السماء اوكرانيا
لقيت رديفها الروسي فرد الروسي على
المسيرات الاوكرانيه حلقت به قنابل مجنحه
جديده تعرف بالقنابل الانزلاقيه لتعويضات
صواريخ كروز هذا السلاح الروسي الاحدث
الذي تجاربه موسكو قد يغير مسار الحرب
ويجبر كييف على اعاده كتابه خطتها
العملياتيه للهجوم المضاد وذلك وفقا
لصحيفه ديل تيليجراف القنابل الانزلاقيه
او قناه للتخطيط اذا هي قنابل جويه مجنحه
وارخص واسهل في الانتاج من الصواريخ
البالسيه وحتى صواريخ كروز تم تزويدها
باجنحه كما تشاهدون وتمنحها نطاقا اضافيا
ومرونه للتحليق على ارتفاعات منخفضه وحتى
بعيده كما ان حجمها الصغير يصعب امكانيه
رصها بواسطه وسائل الدفاع الجوي التقليديه
وبالتالي تجنب مخاطر الطلعات قرب الخطوط
الاماميه في هذه النوعيه من القنابل
التكتيكيه هي مجهزه بانظمه التوجيه
والملاحه بالقصور الذاتي وحتى الاقمار
الصناعيه ما يسمح لها بتحديد مصارحلتها
تجاه الاهداف مباشره مسؤلون اوكرانيون
كانؤكدوا ان الجيش الروسي يطلق ما لا يقل
عن 20 قنبله انزلاقيا يوميا ووصفوها
بالتهديد الخطير للغايه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات